cover some Basics here okay when it
comes to baby step three if you've got
chronic illness in the family I would
lean towards six months if you are
self-employed you're on commission you
have a regular income let's lean towards
six months maybe you have seasonal work
single parent I was lean towards six
months you're um married with one income
you might want to lead towards six
months so who should be saving three
months well if you're single and you
have no dependence and you have a stable
income if you're married with two stable
incomes say you're like three three
months does it for us but it's just
under what your medical deductible is
I'm like let's get to the deductible of
just like having that so that I know if
anything happens I know that the savings
is there for me the minimum for most
people in America I'm saying if you got
ten thousand in the bank you should be
good